bonsoir à tous il y a trois ans un
référendum auprès des intellectuels
désignait claude lévi-strauss comme
l'intellectuel français le plus influent
il devançait rémois rond et michel
foucault
or le paradoxe c'est que cet homme
réputé très influent si les membres de
l'académie française qui a été
professeur au collège de france et aux
études n'est pas connu du grand public
autre paradoxe cet homme très influent
dans la seconde moitié du 20e siècle ne
s'est jamais intéressée qu'aux sociétés
dites primitives et cela d'une manière
discrète et artisanale car claude lévi
strauss est un ethnologue
essentiellement pour celles et ceux qui
n'ont jamais lu et entendu ce savant de
réputation mondiale
je suis allé chez lui dans son bureau à
paris pour lui poser quelques questions
disons primitive claude lévi strauss
claude lévi-strauss ma première question
est somme toute logique
qu'est-ce que l'ethnologie à quoi
servent les ethnologues et au fond que
quoi servi à quoi sert claude
lévi-strauss la dernière je me chargerai
votre réponse vous savez c'est une des
nombreuses manières d'essayer de
comprendre l'homme
si on veut comprendre l'homme ont peu à
la manière du philosophe se replier sur
soi même et essayer d'approfondir les
données de la conscience on peut essayer
de regarder ce qui dans les
manifestations de la vie humaine est le
plus proche de nous considérer notre
histoire depuis ses origines
gréco-romaine jusqu'aux temps modernes
ou bien on peut essayer d'élargir la
connaissance de l'homme pour y inclure
même les sociétés les plus lointaines et
qui nous paraissent les plus humbles et
les plus misérables de manière à ce que
rien d'humain ne nous reste étranger
si je vous entends bien
l'ethnologie ce serait une sorte de
continuation de la réflexion humaniste
sauf que vous allez chercher les sujets
les thèmes de cette réflexion dans des
peuplades qu'on qualifiait il n'y a
encore pas si longtemps de dopage
vous avez tout à fait raison car en fait
ce que les hommes de la renaissance ont
entrepris c'est à dire d'essayer de
mieux se comprendre eux mêmes à travers
le regard sur l'homme de civilisation
qui étaient des civilisations exotiques
je veux dire la grèce et rome
c'était une manière de mettre leur
propre société en perspective de se
mettre eux-mêmes en perspective et puis
après ce premier humanisme
il ya eu un élargissement avec le
développement des moyens de
communication des grands voyages
d'exploration
on a intégré le monde arabe l'inde la
chine le japon et l'ethnologie
représente la troisième est la dernière
étape de cette entreprise humaniste qui
consiste à essayer de comprendre l'homme
par la totalité de ses expériences et
ses réalisations
mais est ce qu'on peut dire des
ethnologues qu'ils vont chercher des
vérités des sagesses qui ne trouvent pas
dans leur propre société
chez eux que je ne dirais pas ça parce
qu'il ya dans notre propre société aussi
des sagesses ne s'est pas du tout en
train de le rabaisser mais simplement
nous essayons de comprendre qu'il y en a
d'autres et que notre sagesse est une
sagesse parmi des centaines ou des
milliers car chacune des quatre ou cinq
mille sociétés je ne dirais pas qu'ils
ont existé depuis que l'homme est apparu
sur la terre parce qu'il y en a eu
beaucoup plus certainement mais sur
lesquels nous possédons quelques
informations ou qui existe encore bien
chacune représente une sage à sa manière
et lui ne pouvant pas essayer de
comprendre la nôtre sans la mettre en
perspective par rapport à toutes celles
là donc l'ethnologie nous invite à une
sorte de modestie d'humilité je crois
que ça a été
on some sa fonction d'eux puisqu'elle
est apparue dans notre littérature si
vous regardez ses premières
manifestations chez rabelais ou chez
montaigne car ce sont les premiers qui
est une curieuse et ethnographique
c'est essentiellement dans leurs pensées
pour faire une critique de nos croyances
de nos coutumes nos institutions mais
par critique je ne voudrais pas du tout
employer un terme qui pourrait être
dépréciatif critiquer c'est essayer
d'analyser c'est essayer de comprendre
c'est d'essayer de mettre en rapport
avec d'autres modes de billets d'autres
modes de pensée je veux maintenant que
nous parlions claude lévi-strauss de
votre sol livre autobiographique qui est
célèbre et paru il ya bientôt trente ans
c'était en 1955 il s'intitule e tristes
tropiques
je les relis j'avais lu à 20 ans j'ai
relu à la faveur de cette de cet
entretien
et je dois dire je le trouve vraiment
sublime et je trouve que la fin je le
préfère le j ai trouvé encore plus de
profits à cette lecture et jeux des je
conseille d'ailleurs à tous ceux qui
voudrait aborder votre oeuvre de
commencer par ce livre ne serait pas ce
qui se passait le plus chatoyant parce
que évidemment c'est le plus facile à
lire
alors est ce que vous vous rappelez que
triste à propos de tristes tropiques
il ya eu un communiqué de l'académie
goncourt regrettant que ce ne fut pas un
roman sinon vous aurez donné le bris je
m'appelle ah oui ça m'a beaucoup surpris
et est-ce que vous rappelez un
feuilleton de raymond aron très très
élogieux je me rappelle bien c'est ça
comptait beaucoup racontent toujours
j'en profite pour vous demander au
passage maisons étaient vos rapports
avec aaron des j'admirais beaucoup
l'oeuvre de
aaron et j'avais pour l'homme une très
grande sympathie
en même temps nous nous sommes je dirais
assez peu connu nous nous rencontrions
au hasard de réunions professionnelles
mais je ne crois pas que nous ayons
jamais déjeuné ou dîné ensemble
alors quand on lit ce livre tristes
tropiques on se dit mais pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas choisi la littérature au
sens strict du terme pourquoi n'avoir
pas choisi le roman le théâtre royal
côté ça je peux tu as bien vous
expliquer parce qu'à l'origine tristes
tropiques dans ma pensée c'était un
roman
quand je suis rentré de ma dernière
expédition est du brésil
aude c'était au début de 1939 et j'avais
donc j'ai donc eu quelques mois pour
essayer de me re est incorporé à la vie
française avant la guerre et la
mobilisation et ses quelques mois je
voulais les utilisent et j'avais décidé
de les utiliser à écrire un roman est un
roman qui s'appelait tristes tropiques
c'était le titre et puis au bout de 50
pages
je me suis aperçu que j'étais en train
de faire du très très mauvais corade
pour qui j'éprouve une admiration
éperdue et que j'étais pas fait pour ça
j'ai donc abandonné
et quand bien des années plus tard
1954 jean mallot vie m'a demandé
d'écrire un livre pour sa toute jeune
collection terre humaine n'est ce pas
qui en était à ses débuts
euh j'ai écrit celui là qui n'est pas un
roman mais où en souvenir j'ai gardé le
titre de ce qu'ils auraient pu être ses
désirs tristes tropiques et uniquement
les trois ou quatre pages du roman qui
m'avait paru pouvoir être sauvée ce sont
les pages imprimées en italie l'été
appelle un coucher de soleil
oui mais juste c'était le début du roman
initialement se coucher de soleil qui
resté célèbre
c'est vrai ces pages c'est pas je prouve
que vous savez admirablement écrit
raconté est dans les détails et j'ai pas
assez d'imagination je ne sais pas
inventer des jeux ne s'est pas créé des
personnages mais comment vous qu'est ce
qu'un ethnologue sait bien que quelqu'un
qui crée lui aussi des personnages ou
bien qu'ils sont vivants niveau il va
dans les détails des chercher je les
lirais qui il est créé hélas parce
qu'ils réinventent mais enfin c'est
parce qu'il voudrait faire il voudrait
être aussi exact et authentique possible
il voudrait copié ses modèles
je me suis demandé d'ailleurs en lisant
soul hip si vous n'avez pas voulu
prouver d'une certaine manière que les
ethnologues ont eux aussi une âme une
sensibilité et même du style vous savez
c'est un livre que j'ai écrit je dirais
presque dans l'exaspération est dans
l'horreur avant oui ça n'est pas du tout
ce que j'avais envie de faire j'avais
envie de faire de la science si vous
voulez et tristes tropiques a été écrit
en quatre mois enfin comme le oui je ne
crois plus que ces éditions sont datés
j'ai demandé que les dates soient
réintégrés dans la prochaine édition
livre de poche ça a été écrit exactement
quatre mois et comme une sorte de pain
somme dont il fallait absolument que je
me débarrasse parce que je n'avais pas
le goût de parler moi j'avais pas le
goût de raconter des petites histoires
des petits détails de voyage et en même
temps je suis bien obligé de constater
rétrospectivement qu'il y a dans tristes
tropiques une certaine vérité
scientifique et paix qui est peut-être
plus grande que dans nous
ouvrage objectif pour autant que ce que
j'ai fait c'est de réintégrer
l'observateur dans l'objet de son
observation
c'est un livre écrit avec ses objectifs
s'appelle l'oeil de poisson jeune homme
qui montrent non seulement ce qui est
bon mais ce qu'il ya derrière l'appareil
de photo et donc ça n'est pas une
relation objective de mes expériences
ethnologique
c'est une relation de moi même en train
de vivre ces expériences ethnologique et
donc avec un tas de choses que je ne me
serais jamais permis d'écrire dans un
ouvrage à ambition scientifique mais
l'exaspération ne se sont pas du tout
absolument pas elle se sent dans cette
espèce de fureur avec lequel j'ai écrit
et qui avec la première édition était
vraiment bourré de toutes les fautes
possibles imaginables même les mots
portugais que j'utilisais puisque ça se
passait grande partie au brésil
vous avez écrit en écriture phonétique
je m'étais même pas occupé du
dictionnaire
ce qui est curieux dans ce livre tristes
tropiques c'est que le court son coût
rappelle incontestablement chateaubriand
et qu'à la fin vous y fait un éloge très
marquée de rousseau rousseau notre
maître rousseau notre frère etc
or il n'ya pas des écrivains plus
dissemblables sinon le le goût qu'ils
ont eu en commun de se raconter fait je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec nous
là dessus et il me semble au contraire
est de plus en plus en vieillissant que
rousseau et châteaubriant c'est une
sorte de couple indissoluble que ce sont
non pas deux personnages mais les deux
faces d'un même personnage qui regarde
dans des directions opposées mais qui
sont tout de même comme des frères
siamois solidairement unis non il ya
d'abord la main
leur écriture au fond personne n'a
jamais écrit le français comme à sa
manière au ruisseau et comme à sa
manière chateaubriand l'on fait ce sont
les deux plus grands exemples de style
et puis il ya aussi cette espèce de
distanciation qui cherche l'un et
l'autre par rapport à leur expérience
par rapport à leur passé rousseau est
allé le chercher et c'est en ce sens
qu'on peut dire qu'il est un des
fondateurs de l'ethnographie il est allé
le chercher
non seulement dans la vie paysanne qui
était fort éloigné pour un homme des
villes et dans les relations des
premiers voyageurs chateaubriand lui est
allé en amérique il en avait donc une
expérience directe et si vous voulez
cette espèce de contrepoint que fait
rousseau entre deux types d'expériences
humaines bien châteaubriant le fait
constamment entre deux types
d'expériences plus rapprochée qui est la
france de l'ancien régime qu'il avait
encore connu la tradition monarchique et
puis ce nouveau monde qu'il voyait
apparaître et tous les noeuds sont
profondément désenchanté rousseau qui
pensaient que ce que nous appelons
aujourd'hui l'époque néolithique c'était
peut-être l'époque qui avait été la plus
favorable
un développement mesuré raisonnable de
l'humanité mais que cet état jamais
révolue chateaubriand profondément
légitimiste fidèle au bourbon mais
sachant même temps que ce passé et est
irrémédiablement condamné c'est je crois
que la différence n'est pas si grande
alors il ya en vous un oeil rousseau est
un homme châteaubriant oui et il ya 30
ans puisque tristes tropiques à 30 ans
si vous voulez chateaubriand rousseau
était peut-être un peu en avant par
rapport à châteaubriant je dirais que
maintenant avec l'âge c'est le contraire
bon alors revenons à vous on apprend en
lisant tristes tropiques que votre
carrière s'est joué je vous cite un
dimanche de l'automne 1934 à 9
du matin sur un coup de téléphone à moi
c'est précis ouais mais c'est tout à
fait vrai j'ai j'avais vu était très
hésitant sur le choix d'une carrière
en fait j'avais commencé à songer
préféré une normale
j'y ai renoncé parce que je n'avais pas
assez bien le grec
mon professeur de cagnes m'a dit vous
n'êtes pas fait pour la philosophie vous
êtes fait pour le droit il sentait qu'il
y avait quelque chose
enfin vous souhaitez pas s'il faut n'est
ce pas j'ai donc commencé des études de
droit
seulement comme c'était très facile à
l'époque savez on apprenait de mémoire
en quinze jours attendre l'examen et
renaillé pas aux cours alors j'ai fait
en même temps une licence de philosophie
et puis je me suis aperçu que c'était
plutôt vers la philosophie que j'allais
bon je suis devenu professeur de
philosophie dans un lycée de province à
mont-de-marsan
oui à mont de marsan s'est d'ailleurs
j'ai commencé à mont-de-marsan le 1er
octobre 1932 et j'ai pris ma retraite le
1er octobre 1982 c'est à dire jour pour
jour cinquante ans après vous voyez
qu'il a précise le calendrier ça compte
dans mon existence et le sentiment enfin
que j'allais passer ma vie y répéter un
cours non c'était pas possible surtout
quand même temps j'avais un très grand
goût de l'aventuré sous des formes très
modeste mais enfin dès l'enfance
j'essayais de transformer disons le
paysage français rural ou urbain en
terrain d'aventuré
comment comment avec mes camarades quand
nous étions ou lycée bon le jeudi ou
dimanche le jeudi c'est jour de congé à
l'époque on se disait on va partir de
tels endroits de paris puis on va
marcher tout droit en direction de la
banlieue on ira exactement aussi loin
mais sans jamais à fléchir notre
direction à droite ou à gauche que nos
jambes pourront nous porter alors ça
nous emmener dans des aventures
extraordinaires aisée du camping alors
oui nous avons fait également du camping
je me rappelle une expérience de camping
nous n'avions pas assez d'argent pour
nous acheter une tente c'était un
article de luxe à l'époque nous avions
loué une bâche que nous transportions
comme un cadavre sur un brancard puis
nous sommes partis des faubourgs de
rouen nous avons marché toute la journée
nous avons dormi dans les positions les
plus inconfortables lendemain matin nous
sommes aperçus que nous étions à 4
kilomètres de rouen parce que nous
avions suivi une boucle de la seine qui
nous avait ramené à notre notre point de
départ et ça a été la fin des italiens
c'est bon mais enfin le camping s'était
pas tellement répandu à cette époque
donc il s'agissait pour moi de tâches et
d'associer une profession qui a été
celle de professeur de philosophie et
puis le goût de l'aventuré dont à ce
moment là
l'ethnologie l'exemple de soustelle le
montrer sous son aile est un petit peu
mon cadet mais lui n'a jamais eu de
doutes sur sa vocation et on savait déjà
à l'époque qui avait un agrégé de philo
mais qui est et parti pour le mexique
qui venait de partir bon je suis dit
pourquoi pas élancé ce coup de téléphone
qui vous a des alors j'ai fait savoir
mme et m que j'aimerais un poste à
l'étranger c'était pas très recherché
vous avez appelé les universitaires
n'aime pas tellement voyagé et un beau
matin bouclés qui était directeur de
l'école normale m'a téléphoné mais est
ce que voulait partir vous êtes parti
pour moi quand une chose étonnante ce
qu'ils avaient des jeunes et quelques
temps après avec l'ambassadeur du brésil
en france qui vous a dit de toute façon
les indiens y en a plus au brésil ah oui
à ce qui nous habite le même mais sa
monnaie mais pas tellement dans les
milieux ça a changé depuis mais dans la
haute bourgeoisie où l'aristocratie
brésilienne on aimait pas tellement se
rappeler qu' il y avait des indiens et
surtout qu'on les avait massacré vous
dit ceci toujours dans tristes tropiques
quand l'ethnographe exerce sa profession
sur le plan scientifique et
universitaire c'est votre cas il ya de
grandes chances pour qu'on puisse
retrouver dans son passé des facteurs
objectifs qui le montrent peu ou pas
adapté à la société où il est né est ce
que c'est votre cas si vous avez écrit
sale voulais je n'ai jamais été en
réalité un homme du siècle où le hasard
m'a fait naître
j'ai toujours été
passionné pour des curiosités exotiques
ou des curiosités d'antiquaires et dans
l'esprit j'ai toujours vécu ailleurs ou
à d'autres époques que la mienne je me
sens réalité nous parlions nous sommes
nous parlions de châteaubriant je me
sens beaucoup plus un homme du xviiie
peut-être du 19e siècle davantage encore
comme de ceux ci à clous en réalité tout
ce que j'aime tout ce à quoi j'attache
du frij suis pas en train de faire son
procès ni de le condamner c'est une
confession autobiographique mais ce soir
je suis en train de vous faire bien tout
ça est en train d'être détruit et
disparaître
moi j'aurais aimé vivre à une époque où
dix ont les moyens de communication
étaient déjà suffisamment rapide pour
qu'on ne passe pas tout son existence
comme marco polo a traversé le monde
mais où en même temps le fait de voyager
pendant trois mois sur la mer où vous
amener à une expérience totalement
irréductibles la salle dans laquelle on
a vécu tandis que maintenant nous
prenons l'habillant nous y sommes en 8h
10h ou en 12 heures et puis qu'est-ce
que nous retrouvons c'est une aérogare
qui est exactement identique à celle que
nous devions qui tient que nous venons
de quitter
donc pour vous à cette époque changer de
de deux continents aller chez les
indiens du brésil
c'était une manière changé de siècle
c'était changer de moins d'échangés de
siècle très certainement
vous voici donc toutes les listes rose
professeur à sao paulo
vous faites très vite de l'ethnologie où
ça prend beaucoup de temps nous sommes
en quelle année en homme sauve au début
35 oui mais ça les jeter complètement
autodidacte en est ne le vivrai jamais
suivi un cours de théologie en france
d'ailleurs il n'existait pas encore de
chair des technologies dans les
universités françaises mais en moins on
pouvait enfin il y avait des
enseignements un peu par un
universitaire et donc je savais rien du
tout alors j'ai commencé j'avais des
étudiants bien sûr nous avons commencé à
faire de l'ethnologie dans la ville
loisirs que la ville m'a toujours
passionné comme objet d'étude parce que
ça s'est constitué à travers les années
en fait chez nous à travers les siècles
les millénaires en amérique du sud plus
récemment mais par une quantité de
petites décisions individuelles sans
aucun plan d'ensemble et avec très peu
et puis peu l'accumulation de ces choix
individuel fait un être qui a eu une
existence une réalité organique et donc
nous avons commencé à travailler dans
san paolo et je demandai je me rappelle
à mes étudiants comme sujet de mémoire
de faire une monographie de la rue dans
lequel il habitait et des choses de gens
et puis dès qu'il y avait un peu de
vacances quelques jours quelques
semaines je file et dans l'intérieur
d'abord pas extrêmement loin mais dans
le sud du brésil enfin jours de voyage
on peut déjà trouver des petits
groupements indien s'est abîmé qui
vivent comme des paysans brésiliens mais
enfin qui sont tout de même des indiens
et j'ai décidé que mes premières grandes
vacances au lieu de rentrer en france
comme faisais mes camarades bien je
filerai chez les indiens dans
l'intérieur
c'est ce que j'ai fait la première la
deuxième année et puis ensuite dont j'ai
rapporté des collections ethnographiques
à paris elles ont été exposées par le
musée de l'homme on a accepté comme un
ethnologue de plein droit et j'ai pu
obtenir des crédits pour faire une
mission d'une année alors dans
l'intérieur tient du ray comme je le
rappelais tout à l'heure jusqu'à la
veille de la guerre votre terrain
d'élection a été d'abord l'amérique
latine et puis ensuite vous allez être
monté l'amérique l'amérique centrale et
l'amérique du nord l'amérique centrale
non ça n'a jamais été mon terrain mais
l'amérique du nord où il par la suite
j'ai vécu aux états unis
j'y suis retourné beaucoup et au canada
et j'ai également un peu travailler mais
en réalité je sais très bien que je ne
suis pas un homme de terrain je n'ai pas
cette patience fantastique qui faut pour
pendant des heures et des heures depuis
6 heures du matin jusqu'à 8 oui il ya un
texte d'ailleurs c'est assez
extraordinaire la soie difficulté du
travail cloud site et bien ce sera une
belle occasion pour les expériences se
rendent compte de votre style à vous dit
ceci un jour vous êtes il ya deux bandes
ennemies qui sont en train de taper une
contre lausanne
les deux bandes ennemies qui s'étaient
rencontrés à composent nouveau toujours
sur le point d'en venir aux mains
nourrissait des sentiments qu'ils
n'étaient pas plus tendre à mon égard je
devais me tenir sur le qui vive et le
travail ethnographique était
pratiquement impossible dans des
conditions normales enquête sur le
terrain se révèle déjà éprouvante il
faut être levés avec le jour rester en
éveil jusqu'à ce que le dernier
indigènes se soit endormi et même
parfois guetter son sommeil s'applique à
passer inaperçu en étant toujours
présent tout voir tout retenir tout noté
faire montre d'une indiscrétion
humiliante mendier des informations d'un
gamin morveux se tenir prêts à profiter
d'un instant de complaisance ou de
laisser aller ou bien savoir pendant des
jours refouler toute curiosité et se
cantonner dans la réserve qu impose une
saute d'humeur de la tribu une
effrayante une grande vie c'est
essentiel a fait si vous considérez que
tous ces efforts sont destinés à
recueillir des informations sur une
expérience humaine qui n'étaient pas
connus qui bientôt n'existera plus et
qui fait pourtant partie du patrimoine
de l'humanité comme un élément
irremplaçable
ça n'est pas payer trop cher mais enfin
je suis pas exactement fait pour ça mais
ça ce sens parce qu'elle est maman
vous vous sombrez pas dans le
découragement mais vous êtes atteint par
le déboisement vous dit ceci est
vraiment surtout on s'interroge qui est
on venu faire ici dans quel espoir à
quelles fins qu'est-ce au juste qu'une
enquête ethnographique
j'avais quitté la france depuis bientôt
cinq ans j'avais délaissé ma carrière
universitaire pendant ce temps mes
condisciples plus agents gravissait les
échelons
ceux qui comme moi jadis avait penché
dans la politique et est aujourd'hui
député bientôt ministre et moi je
courais les déserts en pourchassant des
déchets d'humanité quand quelque chose
qui adore la littérature et
nos graphiques qui a un nom il ya un
homme celui de malinowski que nous
entourons tous de vénération parce que
nous le considérons comme le plus grand
travailleur de terrain qui ait jamais
existé
il a écrit des livres la vie sexuelle
des sauvages de la mélanésie les
argonautes du pacifique et c'est qu'ils
sont de véritables chefs-d'oeuvre par la
sensibilité aiguë en même temps le don
littéraire avec lequel il captive la vie
des sociétés indigènes et puis bien
après la mort de mme annie 9 qui on a
trouvé son journal et on a publié son
journal et dans ce journal
il s'exprime c'était bien
postérieurement à tristes tropiques que
cette publication
il s'exprime exactement dans les mêmes
termes que jean voisin alors même le
plus grand travailleur de terrain et
trouve à certains moments ces sentiments
seulement il y avait aussi une autre
raison c'est que dans l'histoire de
toutes les sciences
enfin je dirais qu'il ya des périodes
fluctuante il ya des périodes où la
première tâche c'est de ramasser s'il a
cumulé des matériaux et là c'est le
travail de terrain qui l'emportent et
puis il ya d'autres moments où la masse
des matériaux accumulés est devenue
telle qu'on n'y comprend rien du tout
c'est devenu une sorte de fouillis un
désordre qu'on ne peut plus maîtriser et
à ce moment là il faut que certains
parmi les représentants de sa science je
lirai pas tous parce que le travail sur
le terrain doit constamment se
poursuivre mais que certains s'arrêtent
un peu et essayent d'assimiler la masse
de matériaux et de les mettre en ordre
et au fond c'est la nécessité que j'ai
ressenti de façon plus aiguë et en
raison des circonstances à l'époque où
je me mettais au travail et en raison de
ses caractéristiques personnelles enfin
dans une part lyon et puis vous dit ceci
est assez curieux quand même une
expédition ethnographiques dans le
brésil centrale se prépare au carrefour
réaumur sébastopol
c'était essentiellement au fait à mon
époque c'est à dire à une époque où il
existait encore je m'ajuste on peut
aller terme et des vrais sauvages
maintenant ce ne serait plus exactement
la vérité puisque je pourrais citer le
cas d'un de mes collègues des meilleurs
qui travaillant sur des gens je ne
dirais pas qu'ils étaient encore à l'âge
de pierre il n'était plus mais il savait
parfaitement encore et faire des
instruments de pierre et saint servir et
bien tout de même pour assister un grand
rituel d'initiation tri secret ce qu'on
lui a demandé comme paiement c'est une
toyota
oui parce que il s'agissait de la
nouvelle guinée
c'est cette tribu commencé à cultiver le
café elle avait besoin d'une voiture
pour aller vendre ses sacs ou les amener
au dépôt sur les pistes alors nous ne
sommes plus à l'heure actuelle à
l'époque des perles de béatrice alors
ouvert fourrant réaumur sébastopol est
chargé d'aider la bimbeloterie oui mais
de la bimbeloterie qui devait être de
d'excellente qualité parce qu'il n'y a
pas de plus grand de plus merveilleux
artisans que ces gens qui sont démunis
tout et vous ne la arriverai pas à les
satisfaire avec des perles qui
déteignent vous employer la même
stratégie que les missionnaires ou les
aventuriers il faut arriver avec des
choses qui brillent
il faut arriver avec des choses qui me
plaisent vous dit à maman et c'est
peut-être une des raisons pour
lesquelles vous vous avez choisi le
l'ethnologie et pourquoi vous y avez
réussi vous dites simplement j'ai
l'intelligence néolithique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire une
intelligence néolithique ça veut dire
que je me sens peu capable de mettre en
culture une terre est de savoir année
après année
l'amendé par des engrais la cultiver
pour en tirer des récoltes de plus en
plus profitable
je suis beaucoup plus tôt au point de
vue intellectuel comme ces indiens que
j'ai connu et que j'ai aimée qui
défriche un morceau de forêt y cultive
pendant deux ou trois ans quelque chose
et puis ensuite la terre est épuisée bon
sens va ailleurs et on met un nouveau
terrain en culture ça c'est l'économie
de la période néolithique et il me
semble qu mon cerveau travaille un peu
de cette façon là je dis pas ça à titre
d love c'est une infirmité plutôt
qu'autre chose vos premiers travaux que
les bistrots sont portés sur les liens
de parenté pourquoi parce que dans les
sociétés qui étudie les ethnologues
l'apparenté constitue je dirais la
marque
l'armature même du groupe social ou bien
on est parent ou bien on est un étranger
et donc à l'intérieur du groupe
tout le monde est parent et ses sociétés
aussi étrange que cela puisse nous
paraître ont des règles de mariage qui
peuvent être d'une complication extrême
pour choisir puisque tout le monde et
par an ce marais y entre par an mais
pour choisir parmi les parents ceux avec
qui on a le droit ou l'obligation ou
bien au contraire on n'a pas le droit de
se poser alors qu'il ya là toute une
espèce
de mécanique tout une géométrie des
rapports sociaux qui est la façon dont
on peut aborder les sociétés humaines
une des façons dont on peut aborder les
sociétés humaines pour comprendre
comment elle fonctionne car gilles aussi
il ya des règles il y à des parents
proches que nous n'avons pas le droit
d'épouser à part ça nous en remettons à
les mécanismes de hasard mais dans toute
société il est clair que les règles du
mariage ou pour objet d'empêcher les
familles en tant qu'unité biologique de
rester closes de se refermer sur
elle-même et de substituer ce qu'on
pourrait appeler des liens sociaux car
les liens d'alliance sont des liens
sociaux aux liens purement biologique de
filiation dans ce livre que vous avez
fait paraître un dernière qui s'intitule
le regard éloigné
vous revenez sur ses liens de parenté
vous dit ceci dans la plupart des
sociétés dites primitives le célibat par
et répugnant et condamnable mais est ce
qu'il y avait vraiment des célibataires
dans les sociétés primitives que vous
avez étudié le cas est extrêmement rare
un précisément parce que l'unité
je dirais non pas seulement de
reproduction mais l'unité de production
l'unité économique étant essentiellement
fondés par le couple conjugal un
célibataire le peut matériellement pas
subsister il ne faut pas oublier que
dans ses sociétés
il y à des tâches qui sont
spécifiquement masculine et d'autres qui
sont spécifiquement féminine etc c'est
donc par l'union des deux sexes que peut
se mener se réaliser une existence
normale
j'ai connu en effet dans une société 7
et sherbrooke jacques roy un individu
qui était
triste salle mal tenues dont je pensais
qu'il était malade
j'ai demandé ce qu'il avait envahi hier
c'est un célibataire en effet pour se
procurer les produits du jardinage
féminin puisque chez les bobos ce sont
les femmes qui cultivent les jardins et
bien il dépend des de la charité de ses
voisins de prochain sur l'infanticide
vous portez un regard non pas
approbateurs mais je dirai ce prêt ainsi
certainement pas maintenant mais
compréhensif
toutes les sociétés ont utilisé des
moyens différents pour maintenir leurs
effectifs dans les limites qui leur
paraissait raisonnable
d'où nous utilisons la contraception qui
n'est pas quelque chose de récent n'est
pas besoin lui dire qu'il existait déjà
du temps des grecs et des romains et
bien davantage encore dans la campagne
française sous l'ancien régime
chez d'autres peuples on supprime les
enfants de leurs enfin certains enfants
dès leur naissance
ça peut être quelquefois les filles
quand on attache un prix particulier
avoir des garçons ça peut être les
jumeaux quand on considère que mettre au
monde des jumeaux c'est ce conduire
comme un animal parce que le propre de
l'humanité c'est d'avoir qu'un enfant à
la fois
ce peut être bon pour mille autres
raisons
mais si on veut regarder les choses d'un
peu loin comme essayent de le faire
l'ethnologue il n'y a pas grande
différence entre supprimer un enfant
avant sa naissance ou le supprimer au
lendemain et puis vous avez consacré
quatre livres rassemblés sous le titre
mythologique à l'étude des mythes alors
dans l'ordre c'est le cru et le cuit du
miel au sens l'origine des manières de
table et l'homme nu alors est ce que
vous pourriez comme ça de dire qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un mythe expliquer aux gens
qui ne savent pas ce cinquième bien
qu'est-ce que c'est un mythe
parce que là ça a été finalement votre
terrain de près près de prédilection le
mythe
enfin ça a été un de mes dieux grand
llodra l'élection semaine écoulée alors
un mythe qu'est ce que c'est
c'est difficile d'expliquer voir c'est
une histoire qui cherche à rendre compte
à la fois de l'origine des choses des
êtres et du monde du présent et de
l'avenir et qui cherche en même temps
simultanément à traiter des problèmes
qui nous apparaîtrait aujourd'hui à la
lumière de notre pensée scientifique
comme tout à fait hétérogènes différents
les uns par rapport aux autres à les
traiter comme si c'était un seul
problème etienne mettez une seule
réponse un mythe c'est par exemple une
histoire qui essayera d'expliquer à la
fois pourquoi il se trouve que le soleil
est à bonne distance de la terre alors
qu'ils pourraient être beaucoup plus
loin et ce serait la nuit éternelle où
beaucoup plus près ils m'ont entrerait
en conflit grâce ion et pourquoi un
homme doit aller chercher son épouse à
bonne distance
pas trop loin parce qu'alors ça pourrait
être une étrangère est une ennemie est
une sorcière pas trop près parce que ils
se rendraient coupables du péché
d'inceste et pourquoi également les
saisons et les jours ne ce succès pas à
toute vitesse mais selon un rythme
régulier
enfin pourquoi il existe une certaine
bonne mesure à la fois dans l'ordre
cosmologique dans l'ordre
météorologiques dans l'ordre saisonniers
et dans l'ordre social nous avec nos
préoccupations scientifiques qui avons
appris avec des cartes qu'il faut
diviser les difficultés en autant de
partis qu'il est requis pour les
résoudre
du considérions que ce sont des
problèmes complètement différent et qui
doivent être posées
chacun dans sa perspective propre et
résolue dans ses propres termes le mythe
au contraire essaye de mettre tout ça
ensemble
et de trouver une réponse unique à des
problèmes différents
je suppose que ces mythes sont
particulièrement vives assez nombreux
dans des sociétés qui n'ont pas
d'écriture
bien sûr dans les sociétés en fait
qu'ils ont pas encore utiliser les modes
de pensée scientifique mais en réalité
quand vous y réfléchissez et quand vous
demandez je ne dirai pas ce que font les
historiens pour qui j'ai le plus grand
respect mais quels usages nous l'ont
fait les hommes de la rue nous faisons
de l'histoire et que celui qui est
gauche
enfin voix l'ancien régime et la
révolution française ce qui s'est passé
ou 19e siècle d'une façon tout à fait
différente que l'homme de droite ne les
verra au fond est-ce que nous
n'utilisons pas l'histoire un peu à la
façon d'un mythe
c'est à dire en l'organisant de telle
façon qu'elle nous aide ou que nous
croyons qu'elles nous aident à mieux
comprendre notre passé notre position
actuelle dans le monde et les choix
politiques que nous faisons mais si je
comprends bien votre travail sur sur ces
mythes
il s'agissait pour vous et pour les
ethnologues de chercher une sorte de
cohérence derrière ce qui nous apparaît
incohérent et même abracadabrant c'est
ça mon travail et connaît aussi bien
pour les rapports de parenté que pour
les mythes font aussi je me suis
intéressé au problème de parenté c'est
parce que nous avons selon les sociétés
toutes sortes de règles qui paraissent
incohérente et absurde
il ya une société qui vous dira la seule
femme qu'il faut épouser
c'est la fille du frère de votre mère
mais si vous vouliez épousé la fille du
racers de votre père ça c'est
l'abomination de la désolation
il ya une autre société qui vous dira
exactement inverse
il ya une société que vous dire allez
bonne façon de se marier c'est d'être
divisés en deux groupes et les hommes du
groupe à épouser les femmes du gobé les
femmes des groupes épouse les femmes du
groupe à y en a une autre qui vous dira
pas du tout il faut plusieurs groupes il
faut qu à d'un abbé ces femmes que b
donne ces femmes assez c'est à un autre
et puis finalement ça reviendra à celui
du départ et tout ça semble
incohérent et si je me suis attaqué à
ces problèmes c'est en me disant il
n'est pas possible que les hommes
passent leur vie à déraisonnée est passé
des siècles et des millénaires et des
centaines de millénaires et quelle est
la logique qui est derrière tout ça et
cette logique il a essayé de la trouver
et avec les mythes c'est la même chose
enfin si c'est tout de même quelque
chose d'irritant de chagrinant de
troublant de se dire depuis ce club
existe depuis beaucoup plus longtemps
que nous le supposions il parle
probablement depuis deux millions
d'années ou même davantage
et depuis dieu millions d'années il se
raconte des histoires qui n'ont
absolument un ni queue ni tête qui sont
absurdes apparat cada brandt ou
n'importe quoi peut arriver et autres et
je me suis attaqué au mythe en me disant
me posant le même problème que pour
l'occasion de parenté est-ce que d'une
certaine manière il n'y a pas derrière
tout ça une logique je suppose claude
lévi-strauss qu'il n'ya pas que les
hommes les femmes les liens par antennes
et les mythes qui sont pour vous plein
d'enseignements il y avait aussi les
objets les vêtements les objets et les
vêtements et je dirais chez ces peuples
que nous étudions
nous appelons à tort primitif il y a
derrière chaque objet il ya un an pile
aa jeu de mythes et de croyances et de
leur présentation
mais vous avez apporté beaucoup d'objets
de journée j'en ai rapporté beaucoup
mais ils sont tous au musée de l'homme
parce que j'étais très puritain si je
puis dire surtout dans mes jeunes années
je considérais documents scientifiques
mais enfin j'ai un peut ramasser des
objets blanche existence oui c'est vrai
c'est que chez vous il ya très très
fière beaucoup de livres mais je vois
très peu je me disais je vais entrer
dans le haut au musée guimet
mais pas du tout alors quand même là je
vois un totem derrière vous qu'est ce
que c'est que ça ce totem c'est un marc
sculpté en réduction parce que ceux qui
se dressent dans les villages de ces
indiens qui sont les
lien aïda qui vivent dans des îles au
large de la côte canadienne du côté de
l'océan pacifique
les villages étaient est hérissé de
grands mâts sculpté qui pouvait avoir 10
12 15 mètres de hauteur et qu'on appelle
totémique parce qu on y voit les animaux
et mais en fait ce sont beaucoup plus
tôt des blasons exactement comme les
blasons de notre moyen-âge où chaque
maison noble parce que ce sont des
sociétés très aristocratique rassemble
des événements caractéristiques ou les
symbolise de sa généalogie en remontant
jusqu'au temps les plus lointains alors
nous parlions tout à l'heure du mythe et
j'essayais de vous dire ce que c'est que
le mythe pour un ethnologue
mais si vous aviez posé la question n
ces indiens vont général à n'importe
quel indien des deux amériques parce que
là il ya une étrange l'unanimité et vous
laisser vous lui avez demandé qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un mythe
il vous aurait répondu c'est une
histoire qui se passe à une époque où
les animaux et les hommes n'étaient pas
réellement distinctes et où il pouvait
passer indifféremment de la forme
humaine la forme animale
ce qui me semble d'une vérité je dirai
presque tragique parce que s'il y a
quelque chose de tragique dans la
condition humaine c'est bien cette
coexistence que nous menons à côté
d'autres êtres qu'ils sont vivants comme
nous et avec lesquels nous ne pouvons
pas communiquer et l'âge du mythe c'est
celui justement où c'était possible et
donc tous ces êtres qui sont représentés
là ne sont pas exactement ni des humains
ni des animaux ce sont des êtres qui
sont à cheval entre les deux natures et
ce qui fait la grandeur de cet art qui
est un des plus
majestueux important que je connaisse
c'est précisément cette extraordinaire
capacité qu'ils ont eue d'exprimer cette
vérité d'euros dreux surnaturel il n'y a
pas du tout le côté caricature ou les
fadaises si vous voulez à la walt disney
ses personnages sont des personnages
monumentaux grandiose ils sont plein de
pensées et en même temps vous ne pouvez
pas dire si 100 des animaux ou des êtres
humains alors dans leur ordre commençant
par an où il ya un énorme saut en
dessous probablement un hibou alors la
grande figurine est plus étrange et si
on veut la lire
on constate d'abord que cette créature à
la bresse est à dire un disque de bois
dans la lèvre inférieure donc c'est une
femme parce qu'il n'y a que les femmes
qui portaient le labret chez les valides
a ensuite parce qu'il s'agit d'un arc et
complètement co des stéréotypes et vous
voyez 3
petit motif en forme de demi lune sur le
front qui représente les ouïes d'un
poisson est en dessous un organe
protubérants qui est la queue alors à
ces signes vous savez qu'il s'agit d'une
rousse est c'est à dire un square un
petit squale bon qu'est ce que ça veut
dire se rappelle que dans l'histoire de
cette famille il ya eu une femme dans
les temps très anciens et à l'époque où
les animaux et les humains n'étaient pas
distinctes qui s'est moqué du peuple des
roussettes et alors ils l'ont entraîné
ans kidnappée et ils l'ont changée elle
même en os 7
et voilà l'incident alors en dessous
quelque chose de très important c'est le
corbeau et le corbeau c'est la
principale divinité de ces peuples qui
ont résolu le problème du mal d'une
façon très différente de la nôtre nous
nous faisons un dieu tout puissant et
très bon et nous n'arrivons pas à
comprendre comment le mal est entrée
dans l'univers eux font un dieu qui est
un trompeur par vocation et par nature
et qui par conséquent fabrique en même
temps le bien et le mal
d'où l'absence totale de problème à se
poser sur l'existence du mal dans
l'univers attachant
oui ils ont bien de la chance et le fait
qu'ils aient des grenouilles se rapporte
à un incident et de grenouilles de jeu
son existence où il avait volé le soleil
qui étaient dans une boîte il a proposé
un peuple en échange de nourriture qui
n'ont pas voulu lui donner alors il les
a changés en grenouille et alors tout en
bas un personnage qui se reconnaît
exactement à certains caractères les
deux incisives fortement marqué la
petite baguette qu'il tient dans ses
deux mains c'est un castor et puis il ya
un mot qu'il faut bien prononcer dans
cette émission
claude lévi-strauss parce que votre nom
y est attaché c'est le mot
structuralisme alors structuralisme pour
ceux qui ne savent pas ce que c'est
c'est quoi c'est une un mode de pensée
une jeu pour une méthode d'analysé une
idéologie qu'est ce que c'est un mot qui
a été tellement mis à toutes les sauces
et oui que moi même je n'ose plus je
n'ose plus l'utiliser parce qu'en
réalité on s'y met cette image inc
c'était une grande nouveauté
pas du tout enfin c'est tout simplement
un effort pour introduire dans les
sciences ou ce qu'on appelle à tort les
sciences de l'homme ou les sciences
sociales parce que nous ne sommes pas
des sciences un petit peu plus de
rigueur que il y en avait précédemment
et en fait est qu'on croit qu' il s'agit
d'une découverte récente non le couac la
façon la plus simple de faire comprendre
aux sculptures l'isthme dire nous avons
à faire nous autres qui ont été liés
étudiants les hommes ou des sociétés
humaines à des objets qui sont
extraordinairement compliquée qui sont
en réalité beaucoup plus compliqué que
les plus compliquées de ce que nos
collègues biologistes ou physicien
études et donc à la limite nous ne
sommes nulle pas capable de décrire de
façon satisfaisante
un petit peu comme un visage humain
enfin vous pouvez
lire pendant vingt pages de prouesses de
la description du visage de la dette de
crécy dit long vous ne verrez pas d'être
de crécy que ce que vous saurez ce
qu'elle n'avait aucun rapport avec un
rooney la mythique mais vous ne saurais
pas vous ne saurez pas vraiment vous ne
pourrez pas voir le visage de la grèce
et 7 à l'époque de la renaissance d'un
grand peintre allemand albert durèrent
s'est aperçus parce qu'il était peintre
c'était un problème qui le préoccupait y
dessiner que s'ils n'étaient pas
possible de décrire très exactement un
visage et un autre visage on pouvait
trouver une règle de transformation très
simple qui permettait de passer de ce
visage à un visage b par une déformation
en elle-même facile à réaliser et bien
au fond le structuralisme c'est en face
d'objets très compliqué de se dire nous
n'essayerons pas de décrire ces objets
dans les moindres détails parce que nous
n'y arriverions jamais une vie ne serait
pas suffisante pour décrire une heure de
la vie d'une société humaine de 50
personnes mais nous essaierons de
comprendre quelle est la différence
entre cette société et une autre société
et nous apercevons que si chacune de ces
sociétés prises apparaît très compliqué
en réalité la différence entre elles la
relation entre elle et peut-être plus
simple flic maintenant que nous en
revenions à tristes tropiques et puis à
la parenthèse que fut dans votre vie
comme d'ailleurs beaucoup de la vie
d'homme de la guerre et vous raconter
dans une autre pique que vous avez fait
connaissance d'andré breton sur le
bateau qui vous emmenait qui vous
emmener d'abord je crois à pointe à
pitre
j'ai amené à l'amertume à ses saveurs de
france et puis ensuite vous êtes devenu
son ami vous avez vécu aux états unis
réfugiée avec qui vous êtes devenus amis
mais alors je travaille votre témoignage
sur andré breton basque a toujours dit
qu'il avait un caractère impossible et
c'est quoi leur est breton était un
personnage qui était loin d'être simple
comme il y un instant c est à la fois un
homme d'une courtoisie extraordinaire
qui avait un côté grand siècle qui était
fidèle dans ses amitiés jusqu'au jour où
il y avait quelque chose qui craquait et
d'ailleurs entre nous quand tout le
monde ya eu un jour tel que face à
craquer aux avez vous quelque chose qui
a craqué sur une histoire absurde
s'arrête jamais pu imaginer qu'ils
purent tirer un sujet de mécontentement
mais enfin bon
ensuite ça s'est arrangé un peu mais ça
n'a jamais été la grande amitié du
capitaine paul lemerle ces faits le nom
du bateau et ensuite de nos années de
new york pendant lesquelles avec max
ernst
nous courions les petits antiquaires à
la recherche d'objets du genre de celui
ci qui à cette époque là étaient
considérés comme de purs document
ethnographique sans aucune valeur
esthétique c'est vraiment nous qui avons
appris aux américains que ces objets
étaient beaux et breton était un
les bretons avaient entre mille d'allant
et pas seulement un grand poète un grand
écrivain
il avait une sorte de sens infaillible
de l'objet en fait il n'avait jamais la
moindre hésitation devant un objet pour
savoir non seulement s'il était
authentique ou s'ils étaient faux mais
de savoir s'il était vraiment beau ou
pas vous nous a expliqué tout à l'heure
que vous avez vous avez embrassé
l'ethnologie pour fuir l'enseignement
mais je remarque que l'ethnologie vous a
ramené à l'enseignement puisque après
vous êtes vous êtes vous avez été
professeur aux études puis finalement
professeur au collège de france
oui mais je n'ai jamais appartenu à une
université
c'est à dire que j'ai appartenu ce qu'il
est convenu d'appeler des grands
établissements où il n'y a pas un
programme ou au contraire la règle et il
n'y en a qu'une mais elle est impérieuse
c'est que chaque année vous devez faire
quelque chose de nouveau et ça c'était
évidemment la façon pour moi de
concilier l'enseignement et le côté
instable et inquiet du ma nature
c'est que chaque année il fallait
changer c'est une manière peut-être
aussi préparer des livres à tous mes
livres ont été préparés landigou codevi
souviennent paraître cette semaine aux
éditions plon qui est votre éditeur
depuis très longtemps
puis transmettra un livre fait
d'ailleurs de textes très très court
intitulé parole donnée qu'est ce que
c'est que ce livre bien ce sont les
résumés de mes cours
les comptes rendus du mes cours que la
règle la nuit istres hâtive veut que
l'on publie chaque année dans l'annuaire
de l'établissement auquel on appartient
et ces résumés de cours dont certains
sont très bref une page et demie de page
certains au contraire
douze ou quinze pages c'est tout de même
assez condensé eux c'est au fond si vous
voulez un peu à la façon de tristes
tropiques bien que de façon plus austère
ma biographie intellectuelle pendant
trente deux ans voilà ce à quoi j'ai
pensé voilà ce que j'ai racontée enfin
ça c'est autant tristes tropiques
s'adresse au grand public autant ils ont
choisi m'étendrai absolument pas
attendre et sur les best sellers
certaines offres certainement bon
puisqu'on parle de l'enseignement qu'est
ce que vous pensez de la formidable
corel aujourd'hui à propos feu plutôt
des critiques que l'on porte contre
l'enseignement secondaire notamment et
je pense d'ailleurs un collègue de
nouveaux collègues du collège de france
à soutenir au mieux et oui qu'est-ce que
vous de créer un très beau livre et avec
lequel je suis entièrement d'accord
je ne pense pas je ne crois pas que qui
failli daté de 60 8 août une autre année
celle que vous voudrez la décadence de
l'enseignement secondaire fond j'ai
l'impression que je les d'abord que je
l' ai moi même vécu comme élève quand
j'ai appartenait et ensuite comme
professeur je veux dire comme élève
parce que quand je lis des textes du 19e
siècle
je suis absolument stupéfait de voir
quel degré de maturité en classe de
première ou en classe de philosophie
avaient atteint des sommes comme proust
comme jaurès comme berck sonne comme
dürckheim enfin ils étaient tous à peu
près contemporains et ils étaient
beaucoup plus mûr beaucoup plus adulte
dans leur dernière année du lycée que
moi même et mes camarades ne l'étions
déjà dans oui parce que j'allais vous
donnait dès l'époque où à la même
période
je vais vous dire on est des êtres
exceptionnels malhomme vous comparez des
êtres exceptionnels de gens d'en face de
votre époque enfin si je les compare aux
meilleurs de ces classes
lisa était évidemment très au dessus et
j'ai l'impression que nous avons affaire
à une sorte de deux processus mais qui
s'est étendue à travers les siècles et
que j'appellerais presque
d'infantilisation progressive de la
jeunesse et de l'adolescence enfin nous
devenons adulte de plus en plus tard
j'ai pas besoin de vous rappeler
montaigne qui par les grecs et latins à
5 en occident d'ailleurs dans le regard
éloigné vous consacrez un chapitre à
lancer nos époux l'attitude il veut dire
drôle propre aux retardataires sur
l'enfant créateur savoir comment vous
dites je sais qu'on ne m'écoute rappaz
aba les était doublement retardataires
parce que c'était des choses que je
n'avais pas dit au moment où j'aurais dû
les dire et qui ensuite paraissent
retardataires à beaucoup d'éducateurs
compte emploi oui évidemment retardée
parce que vous y faites l'éloge de la
contrainte de l'école je n'en fais pas
l'éloge
j'essaye de montrer que c'est un élément
essentiel de toute éducation quelles
qu'elles soient et quand ce fait de
grandes illusions quand on s'imagine
qu'il suffit de libérer la spontanéité
créatrice une spontanéité créatrice qui
ne vient pas buter contre quelque chose
n'arrive pas à se manifester et se
réaliser et alors je suis absolument
stupéfait quand je vois dire on ne doit
pas proposer à un jeune lycéen vers de
racine comme thème de composition et en
même temps dire on doit lui donner une
feuille de papier
les crayons de couleur et le laisser
s'exprimer se manifester comme si le
vers de racine n'était pas une
résistance tout à fait comparable à
celle du papier à celle des des crayons
et qu'il faut maîtriser une matière pour
arriver à s'exprimer vous citez
d'ailleurs un 4e revers de richard
wagner
apprenez les règles des maîtres pour
qu'elle vous aident à préserver ce qu'on
vaut plus jeunes années le printemps et
l'amour vous en révéler et pourtant
c'était un grand révolutionnaire en
musique
je remarque aussi que lévi-strauss que
vous employez à bon escient et toujours
avec élégance l'imparfait du subjonctif
qui s'emploie rarement maintenant j'ai
un certain amour de la langue mais
disons et de ses ressources et au fond
je ne vois pas pourquoi ce français qui
a été un instrument de communication
tellement parfait qui a eu une époque où
toute l'europe le préférer au langue du
cru pourquoi on l'appauvrir et de
certaines ses moyens d'expression
est ce que votre entrée à l'académie
française et elle est ce que ce n'est
pas le signe justement de la volonté
chez vous de perpétuer des valeurs
anciennes et l'académie française en est
une la nuit française et peut-être de
toutes les institutions françaises
celle qui depuis 350 ans est le moins
changé
et donc elle est digne du respect et de
l'admiration que nous avons pour ses
monuments historiques est après tout un
monument historique n'est pas simplement
fait de pierre ou de peinture il est
aussi faire d'idée de genre de réflexion
de croyance de penser est ce que
symbolise toujours aujourd'hui
l'académie française et c'est un cas je
pense unique dans tous les pays du monde
c'est la proclamation que la langue est
un souci d'état ça ça n'existe nulle
part ailleurs
d'où les travaux du dictionnaire d'où
les travaux du dictionnaire vous trouvez
pas que les les 40m habits verts forment
une sorte de peuplades relevant des tno
de l'ethnologie tout relève de l'état
moi je trouve particulièrement les
habits verts bon nous avons des équipes
qui travaillent dans des villages
français et qui feront de la très bonne
ethnologique vous intéressez vous que
les bistrots salle aventure spatiale ce
que vous trouvez ça avec passion je suis
ça oui quand j'ai une possibilité de
voir à la télévision
je me rappelle est arrivée des hommes
sur la lune oui oui mais je veux dire à
ce que le metn hologue que vous êtes des
réflexions particulière surtout bien si
vous regardez ça comme un citoyen normal
et oui et c'était à la fois beaucoup
d'admiration pour les prodiges signifie
qu'ils ont permis et en même temps une
certaine tristesse car à quoi ça
ressemble ça ressemble à la découverte
de l'amérique par christophe colomb en
492 c'était aussi un autre monde et qui
pouvait paraître aussi loin houcine
atteignable avec les moyens dont on
dispose et alors que la lune aujourd'hui
et ce monde c'était un monde d'une
richesse prodigieuse et qui vraiment
apporté à l'humanité une moitié
d'elle-même qu'elle ignorait à la flore
à la faune et des espèces animales
jamais connu enfin nous vivons toujours
d'ailleurs sur ce que nous avons acquis
l'amérique
et qu'est ce qui nous reste il nous
reste on la lune ou une autre planète où
il n'ya pas d'habitants où il n'y a pas
de plan tout il n'ya pas d'animaux en
fait ce qui nous reste à découvrir en un
sens c'est bien triste
autrement dit la découverte de
l'amérique évidemment plus important au
regard de l'histoire que la découverte
que ça janvier il faut jamais dire des
choses comme ça ah bon parce que
l'histoire est bien prévisible de bruit
dans la bon je vous avais dit tout à
l'heure que bon ce siècle finalement n'a
pas n'avait pas une grande passion pour
lui mais j'ai quand même envie de vous
demander ce que vous intéresser à la
politique au jour le jour
je me tiens au courant je lis plusieurs
journaux je lis plusieurs hebdomadaires
avouez quand même beaucoup de gens nous
alors plusieurs journaux hebdomadaires
c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus que la
moyenne nationale
je lis au moins deux journaux par jour
une quotidien quelquefois trois et je
lis 85,1 bio manière dont j'essaye
j'essaye de me tenir au courant
je ne peux pas dire que j'y mets
beaucoup de mon coeur si vous voulez
j'ai le sentiment j'ai fait beaucoup de
politiques dans ma jeunesse où il était
à l'essai fille au jourdain jeunesses
socialistes étaient j'ai été secrétaire
général la fédération des étudiants
socialistes j'ai même été candidat au
conseil général dans les landes
ça n'a pas donné grand chose parce que
je me suis cassé la figure en voiture là
c'était le premier jour où je prenais
volant d'une voiture j'avais même pas
terminé de conduire et donc ça a mis un
terme est très rapide à ma campagne
électorale
mais j'ai eu avec le passage des ans le
sentiment que j'avais fait de graves
erreurs
à l'époque lesquels ben euh j'ai été
pacifiste avant 39
et puis ensuite j'ai vécu un drôle de
guerre sur la ligne maginot et puis
ensuite la retraite atteint vers la
france puis bon bah quand on a fait une
erreur de ce genre dans sa vie on ne se
mêle plus de juger des choses qui
relèvent d'une autre forme d'esprit d'un
autre type de compétences mais dites moi
que lévi-strauss et tous les hommes
politiques
havel avait la même réaction que vous
saisir la première groix grave erreur je
m'arrête il n'y aurait plus d'hommes
politiques ne trouvez pas j'ai le
sentiment que si j'avais fait
non mais tu y es d'ethnologue une
carrière de une erreur de ce calibre je
ne seraient plus autorisées convient
plus cru autorisé à continuer et la
radio la télévision vous vous écoutez
vous regardez j'écoute essentiellement
de la musique pour autant que je peux
encore en écouter oui à l'an passé alors
je vais vous aborder ça parce que votre
grande passion je crois c'est votre
autre grande passion c'est la musique
bon c'est la musique et enfin j'ai tout
à fait la possibilité d'écouter de la
musique un travail en veut dire je fais
ça avec un deux hémisphères différentes
du cerveau
abbas est salée demi-sphère
chateaubriand et arrosant voilà ça y est
si vous voulez je peux très
difficilement travailler sans la musique
qu'ils n'iraient pas du tout me fait un
fond sonore comme le prétendent certains
c'est pas ça ça voulait qu'on cite ça
excite le fonctionnement de mes cellules
cérébrales
vous pouvez écrire comme ça en écoutant
de la musique je ne peux vraiment bien
décrire bonne écoute à cet effet curieux
mais vous jouez d'un instrument ou dans
ma jeunesse je vais essayer de jouer de
tous les instruments jamais réduit un
résultat quelconque avec aucun est il
vrai mais j'ai lu ça quelque part que
vous auriez mettre un chef d'orchestre
oui mais ça c'est alors ça c'est
profondément vrai ah oui enfin oui si
j'avais pu enfin si une bonne fée venez
me proposait de recommencer mon
existence va ce serait comme compositeur
ou comme chef à défaut comme chef leur
casse
vous êtes à la retraite aujourd'hui
comment vivez vous à quoi employés vous
vos journées j'ai beaucoup plus de
travail qu'avant fichtre parce que quand
j'étais en fonction et que
je dirigeais les laboratoire
d'anthropologie sociale que j'ai fondées
j'avais tout un secrétariat à ma
disposition que je n'ai plus puisque je
vais passer à mes successeurs
mais même plus de secrétaire non donc je
dois faire beaucoup de courriers moi
même et ça prend beaucoup de temps mais
et puis je continuer à écrire mais vous
n'êtes plus de secrétaire parce que vous
n'en voulez pas ou parce que vos moyens
ne nous permettent pas de deux pays ne
serait pas vrai moyen de me le faire
mais certainement pas à part ça pose des
problèmes de place de locaux oui mais
alors ça c'est quand même surprenant
parce qu'un homme de votre compétence de
votre notoriété et je tousse un peu
dommage qu'on ne vous facilite pas la
vie
mais vous savez les usages français ne
sont pas les mêmes que les usages à
l'étranger ont défilé aux états unis un
professeur à la retraite comme servent
exactement les mêmes moyens de travail
qui l'avait auparavant
est ce que dans les chais les peuples
enfin si ce n'est qu'ils sont et un peu
à peu s contre était mieux leurs grands
ancêtres lors langrand doyen leur grand
maître
je dirais que ça dépend tout à fait des
peuples là il ne faut pas généraliser
mais si vous prenez ce dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure à propos de ce
mât sculpté bien les auteurs de ces
sculptures
je vous lis et certainement du même
prestige qu un picasso un matisse parmi
nous il y un mot que nous n'avons pas
encore prononcé claude lévi-strauss et
dont l'absence étonnerait c'est le mot
écologie est ce que les ethnologues
n'ont pas été avant tout le monde les
premiers écologistes
je pense que c'est vrai et c'est vrai
parce qu'ils sont à l'école de peuples
qui eux mêmes sont des écologistes qui
ont réussi au prix de toutes sortes de
pratiques que nous jugeons
superstitieuse et avec un peu de dédain
mais à se maintenir un équilibre avec le
milieux naturels savez quand parmi ces
peuples que nous étudions comme ceux
d'amérique du sud et également du nord
il existe des croyances en 1 m des
animaux qui veille jalousement sur les
procédés de chasse et dont on sait qu'il
enverra des châtiments surnaturel à
celui ou à ceux qui tueraient plus qui
n'est strictement nécessaire quand pour
cueillir la moindre plante médicinale
il est nécessaire de faire d'abord des
offrandes à l'esprit de cette plante est
bien que tout cela oblige entretenir
avec la nature des rapports mesurer et
certains peuples ont même cette croyance
que le capital de vie qui était la
disposition des êtres faites une masse
et par conséquent chaque fois qu'on en
prend trop dans une espèce on doit le
payer aux dépens de la sienne propre
comme c'est un banquier vourla le conti
bien au rouge
et bien tout cela bien sûr frappe
l'ethnologue et lui montre à quel point
une façon je dirais sens et pour l'homme
de vivre est de se conduire et de se
considérer non pas comme nous l'avons
fait depuis géré presque depuis l'ancien
testament et le nouveau et depuis la
renaissance aussi comme les seigneurs et
les maîtres de la création mais comme
une partie de cette création que nous
devons respecter puisque ce que nous
détruisons ne sera jamais remplacé et
que nous devons transmettre telles que
nous
monsieur à nous descendre ça c'est une
grande leçon je dirais presque que c'est
la plus grande leçon que l'ethnologue
peut tirer de son métier mais pensez
vous avez une chance d'être entendu que
l'homme renonce à ned à être le seigneur
la création vous y croyez non très
franchement je n'y crois pas et c'est
pour ça que je ne suis pas optimiste et
que je ne me sens pas très à l'aise dans
la société ou dans la civilisation ou
julie vous êtes retourné au brésil où
vous avez l'intention d'y retourner
je ne suis jamais retourné au brésil et
fait beaucoup d'occasions de le faire et
surtout cette année où se célèbre le 50e
anniversaire de l'université de st par
l'eau je veux dire que j'ai un petit peu
de réticence aller pleurer sur mes
souvenirs de jeunesse et de retrouver
des régions que bien sûr je voudrais
revoir mais que j'ai mieux des mois à
parcourir sur le dos d'un mulet ou en
pirogue même à pied de les trouver
traversé par des routes et des indiens
que j'ai connu encore dans une fraîcheur
j'ose à peine dire primitif parce que ce
serait exagéré mais enfin menant une vie
traditionnel réduits à des sortes de
clochards de part et d'autre de route où
circulent des camions enfin j'ai à la
fois envie et pas envie ça n'est pas au
fond le on a raison de dire que le que
le prédateur de l'homme c'est l'homme
lui-même c'est bien ça vis à vis de
l'homme très certainement enfin j'ai
l'impression que notre civilisation
seuls les blocs de telle façon que nous
devenons un peu vis-à-vis de nous-mêmes
comme les peuples que nous autres fois
que nous deux mignons vu douze
exploitations l'été par rapport à nous
nous devons nous devenons nos propres
collègues disaient pessimistes vous avez
prononcé le mot il ya un instant et
pourtant il ya en vous
sert ce pessimisme je ne sais pas une
sorte de gravité sow rennes presque je
disais tout à l'heure qu'il ne faut
jamais faire de prophétie ou de
prévision et là encore je pense que je
peux me tromper qu'après tout l'humanité
qui a pensé par beaucoup d'événements
difficiles et de circonstance délicate
peut très bien trouver le moyen encore
de se sortir de celle-ci
puis il ya autre chose 6 brûlés qui me
donne le ce que vous appelez de la
sérénité c'est la croyance que j'ai dans
la valeur et l'importance de la pensée
scientifique et notre civilisation avec
toutes ces fautes je dirais même
quelquefois tous ces crimes a en tout
cas quelque chose à son actif qui est
d'avoir les saints donné naissance à la
pensée scientifique et de l'avoir
développé au cours des 50 dernières
années
plus qu'elle ne l'avait jamais été dans
les années antérieures et cet effort
saoulé de l'homme pour comprendre nous
nous savons d'ailleurs très bien qu'il
n'arrivera jamais à son terme qui ne
peut pas arriver à son terme
que comprendre quelque chose c'est en
même temps à percevoir de nouvelles
difficultés qu'on ne comprend pas
attirant sera ainsi indéfiniment je ne
suis pas du tout scientiste à la façon
du 19e siècle mais qu'en tout cas cet
effort pour comprendre et dont les cno
loeb va étudier justement les formes les
plus étrangère à la nôtre chez des
peuples lointains
ben c'est ce qui fait la grandeur de
l'homme c'est ce qui lui donne sa
dignité en avril 80 journal littéraire a
publié un référendum auprès des
écrivains des intellectuels des
professeurs des artistes des
journalistes le la question gros c'était
après la mort de sa fille at il des
maîtres à penser
et vous êtes arrivé en tête le point on
a dit non il ya un lien grands maîtres à
penser actuellement c'est lévi-strauss
devant aaron et devant foucault ça a dû
vous surprendre ou pas vous déjà m'a
beaucoup surpris et en même temps je
n'ai pas été dupe de ce qui était tout
de même un petit jeu de société est la
raison pour laquelle
mon nom c'est trouver le plus souvent
cités je crois que c'est pour des
raisons négatives aux coûts plus que
positive
je ne sais pas ce que tout ce je gêne le
moins de monde
non je vous expliquais pourvoir je pense
que sartre et aaron sont des maîtres à
penser qu'ils disent ce qu'il faut
penser vous vous êtes un maître à penser
je sais que vous récusez se taire mais
vous êtes à mettre à penser qui dit
comment il faut penser c'est tout à fait
différent je dis comment je pense mais
je m'en voudrais et d'ailleurs c'est un
fait que je n'ai pas fait école dans ses
50 ans de carrière universitaire j'ai eu
beaucoup de collaborateurs autour de moi
mais tous ceux qui connaissent un peu
par exemple laboratoire d'anthropologie
sociale où il ya trente chercheurs
savent que ces trente chercheurs ne sont
en aucune façon mes disciples que chacun
travaille dans la voie qui lui est
propre et fait toujours encouragé et à
en faire autant
donc le terme de maître à penser me
sembles immérité est à présent de votre
esprit comme on disait dans le
questionnaire marcel proust est à
présent de mon esprit c'est que j'ai 75
ans que je sais que le nombre d'années
qui me reste à vivre et mesuré que
probablement le nombre d'années où je
resterai lucide à supposer que je sois
encore mettant encore plus mesuré que
j'ai dans mes dossiers dans mes fichiers
à un certain nombre de thèmes que je
n'ai pas eu le temps d'explorer et que
voilà
si j'ai la possibilité d'écrire encore
dans ma vie deux ou trois livres
c'est tout ce que je peux demander à
l'existence
[Musique]